The Marvel Cinematic Universe has had plenty
of highs over the past decade, like "Avengers:
Endgame," and the occasional lows.
"I better get my pants."
But there's one universal truth that every
single fan can get behind: Miss Minutes is
brilliant in "Loki."
The mascot/A.I. helps run the Time Variance
Authority, also known as the TVA.
She also charmed viewers from the instant
she was introduced.
Loki first sees the animated character in
the informational videos playing in the TVA's
waiting area.
Basically, Miss Minutes is a splash of brilliant
creativity in the cosmic bureaucracy that
makes the idea of the TVA go down a little
easier for audiences in the series' first
episode.
However, many viewers of the show quickly
deduced that there is much more to Miss Minutes
than meets the eye.
Towards the beginning of the show's sixth
episode, the adorable clock is revealed to
have a direct line to the man behind the curtain,
He Who Remains.
When Loki and Sylvie manage to enchant their
way into the Citadel at the end of Time, Miss
Minutes revels in offering the pair everything
they've ever wanted in exchange for taking
over the TVA.
Miss Minutes might be some kind of virtual
A.I., but she's clearly got a devilish side
— something she's likely inherited from
He Who Remains.
The script originally gave Miss Minutes much
more to do in the season finale.
In fact, she was supposed to fight Loki and
Sylvie when they arrived in the citadel.
Unfortunately, the closest viewers actually
got to seeing a battle with Miss Minutes was
a jump scare and a couple of quickly drawn
weapons.
"Hey, Y'all."
But how exactly would a fight scene work in
this context?
It's not clear how Miss Minutes can affect
the real world, although we did see Loki try
unsuccessfully to swat her with a magazine
in the second episode of the season.
Director Kate Herron opened up about the cute,
yet sinister, character to Marvel.com.
She explained…
"Early on in the scripts, we all were definitely
united on, 'We've got to keep Miss Minutes
in the story somehow.'"
The director pointed out that she tempts both
of the variants with all they've ever wanted.
"That devil on the shoulder and trying to
tempt both Loki and Sylvie.
It was fun that you got a sense of there's
something a bit more sinister going on here
with her."
"You want the Infinity Gauntlet?
Yours.
Throne of Asgard?
No problem."
And according to Herron, Miss Minutes almost
had a bigger role in the finale.
"We always had a version where [Loki and Sylvie]
kept meeting her at the Citadel.
At one point, we had a fight scene with Miss
Minutes in the Citadel."
Because much of "Loki" Episode 6 was dedicated
to He Who Remains explaining exactly who he
is in exposition-heavy monologues, it's easy
to see why the focus was on the new villain.
"We're all villains here."
Still, it's obvious that there are plenty
of fans who would like to see more of Miss
Minutes in the future.
And it's easy to speculate about the character
and her role in both the TVA and the Marvel
Multiverse as a whole.
Now that the season finale of "Loki" has blown
the doors off the Sacred Timeline, who is
to say that we won't see an expanded role
for the charming A.I.?
Considering her connections to He Who Remains,
we wouldn't be shocked if she's full of previously
unheard information about the TVA and the
Multiverse.
So, even if Miss Minutes doesn't get more
screen time on "Loki," there's certainly room
for a cameo in another Marvel project.
With Season 2 on the way, it would be criminal
for Miss Minutes to not return, so here's
hoping she finally gets a fight scene in the
next batch of episodes.
If that's not in the cards, don't fret.
There's too much love for her from the show's
creators to ignore the potential for another
appearance.
Even if she isn't a focal point of a branching
timeline, she knows enough to cross over to
another world, just as she has into the hearts
of Marvel fans.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.